♪♪
Narrator: CURIOSITY HAS BEEN
ROLLING AROUND MARS SINCE 2012,
AND THE IMAGES IT'S BEEN
SENDING BACK HAVE BEEN STUNNING.
SEQUENCES LIKE THIS BLUE SUNSET
ARE STARTING TO CHANGE
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE PLANET.
BUT IT'S THE PICTURES FROM
THE MARS RECONNAISSANCE ORBITER,
OF A REGION CALLED
THE NEWTON CRATER,
THAT ARE HELPING
TO SHED NEW LIGHT
ON THE AMOUNT OF LIQUID WATER
LEFT ON MARS.
THIS IS A TIME-LAPSE
SEQUENCE SHOWING STREAKS
ON THE CRATER WALL, APPARENTLY
GROWING AND GETTING DARKER.
SCIENTISTS THINK THAT
THEY MIGHT BE CAUSED BY WATER.
SMALL AMOUNTS OF WATER,
COMPARED TO AN OCEAN ON EARTH
OR EVEN AN OCEAN ON EARLY MARS.
THEY'RE INSIGNIFICANT.
BUT AS AN INDICTOR OF MARS
STILL BEING ACTIVE
AND STILL HAVING LIQUID PHASES
AND MAYBE A HINT OF BIGGER
AND BETTER THINGS ELSEWHERE,
THEN I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
Narrator: WHAT APPEARS
TO BE HAPPENING
IS THAT THE MOISTURE
IN THE SOIL
IS EVAPORATING DURING
THE RELATIVE WARMTH OF THE DAY
AND CONDENSING BACK AT NIGHT
WHEN IT'S COLDER.
McKay: SO MARS STILL HAS
A HEARTBEAT. IT'S A FAINT ONE,
IF WE MEASURE ITS HEARTBEAT
IN TERMS OF PRESENCE OF WATER.
AT ONE TIME, IT WAS HUGE.
IT WAS AN OCEAN.
AND NOW THERE'S JUST
A FAINT GLIMMER OF IT.
Narrator: THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THESE SMALL AMOUNTS OF WATER
ARE EXCEPTIONALLY SALTY.
THE CURIOSITY ROVER HAS
IDENTIFIED IN THE MARTIAN SOIL
A SALT CALLED
CALCIUM PERCHLORATE.
IT'S THIS SALT
THAT ABSORBS THE MARTIAN DEW
AS IT CONDENSES
ONTO THE COLD SURFACE EACH DAY.
THE SALT ALSO LOWERS
THE WATER'S FREEZING POINT,
KEEPING IT A LIQUID
EVEN AT SUBZERO TEMPERATURES.
BUT IT ALSO MAKES THESE FAINT
TRACES OF BRINE SO CONCENTRATED,
THEY WOULD BE TOXIC
TO CONVENTIONAL LIFE-FORMS.